- Hello and welcome back
to Khan Academy Live SAT.
I'm Eric, I'm an SAT tutor and one of the
SAT experts here at Khan Academy
and today is our third and final class
as a part of this series.
We've covered SAT math two weeks ago,
last week we covered SAT reading,
and today will be on SAT writing.
Now if you missed any of those
previous classes don't worry.
Just head to our YouTube channel and
you can find the class recording there
where you can re-watch, pause,
fast-forward, do whatever you need
to get what you want out of those videos.
If you're joining us for the first time,
one quick tech tip to help you get
the most out of this class
is to go to full screen
on YouTube and try and up the resolution
to the best quality that you can,
because we'll be going through
real SAT writing questions,
and so being able
to read everything will be really helpful.
So today's class is on SAT writing,
so before we dive into the materials
let's take a look at the topics for today.
So first up I'm gonna do some instruction
and some practice problems, and so the
first thing I'm gonna do is provide
a quick overview of the writing test
and share some tips for how you can
mark up the test and be more proactive
when it comes to SAT writing questions.
Next up I'm gonna cover
subject-verb agreement
and do some practice problems,
and third I'm going to go over
sentence punctuation and again
do some real practice problems.
In the middle I'll pause for some Q and A,
and actually as I'm going through
this writing class feel free to throw in
any questions that you
have as I'm going along
into the YouTube chat and then I'll
get to as many as I can
in the middle there.
And then finally I'm
going to close things out
by working through an SAT writing passage,
and so this is going
to be a 45 minute class
all told, and so that's a sneak peak
at what is ahead and so there's a lot
of material to cover, a lot of grammar,
a lot of writing concepts to learn,
and so let's jump into
the very first topic.
So first a quick overview of the
SAT Writing and Language Test.
So in total this is a 35 minute section
and you have 35 minutes
to do four passages
with 11 questions each, and so what I want
to emphasize here is
that means you do need
to move at a decent pace throughout,
but you'll notice that
all of these questions
come within passages, and so
context is very important.
It's a bit like the SAT
reading section in that
what comes before and after the question
makes a very, is really important
in helping you find the right answer.
So that's what you'll have to expect,
and then in terms of
topics and passage types,
here's a sneak peak at
that, and so you'll have
a variety of topics that fall into
a variety of passage type options.
Then in terms of the
questions that you can
expect to see, there are
two that I want to call out.
The first are expression
of ideas questions,
and these really ask you to improve
the effectiveness of a communication,
and so what that means is it might ask you
how you might clarify and
add clarity to the passage.
It might ask you to
strengthen an argument.
So it's all about communicating
the author's point more effectively.
The second question type focuses
on standard English conventions,
and this is probably what you might be
more used to seeing and this is all about
grammar, punctuation, and all those
great rules that you've learned
in your English and reading
classes in high school.
So that's a bit of an
overview of the writing test,
and now I'll move onto how you can
mark up the writing and language test,
and the reason I'm talking about
marking up the writing and language test
is that being proactive is a great
tool not only in math and reading
but also here, and so this really helps
engage your mind as you're reading
through the passage
and working through the
questions if you are marking things up.
And so there are four things
that I always suggest you try.
The first is to annotate
the passage as you go.
So this is underlining and annotating
things like the topic
sentence, which is the
first sentence in the paragraph,
it's circling things like but or however,
these kind of contrast
words that convey meaning,
that sort of thing.
The second thing I suggest is that
you underline the question and the
answer choices, and why this is important
is that you want to make
sure you're answering
the right question, and then on the
answer choices what I would call out
is that one word can make
an answer choice wrong,
can make a choice wrong,
make a choice wrong.
And so this attention to detail
and looking through each answer
choice is really important.
Third thing I would suggest
is to cross out words
to simplify long sentences, and it's all,
this simplification is
the name of the game,
and where you'll see this most often
in the writing test is with something
called a prepositional phrase.
And so prepositional phrases start
with words like like, or above, or before.
So those are a few things
that you want to look out for,
and by crossing out prepositional phrases
you can often simplify subject-verb,
subject-verb agreement sentences.
It can make it much clearer what's
the subject and what's the verb.
Finally, I encourage you to use
process of elimination
and so you can cross out
the letter, you can cross
out the whole thing.
Really the more active
you are in crossing out
things that are wrong, the better it is
so that you don't use any more
mental energy to go through it.
So we'll get a chance to use all of these
tactics in the practice problems ahead
and in the practice writing
and language passage.
So that's a quick overview
of what you might,
what you can expect on the SAT
Writing and Language section,
and a few tips for how
you can be more proactive
as you're working through the passage,
reading it, and doing some questions.
Now we're gonna move onto some grammar,
and hopefully some of this looks
familiar to you, but if not, don't worry.
We're gonna do a quick review and then
do some practice problems to reinforce it.
So let's take a look at the first concept.
So subject-verb agreement
is topic number one.
Now the first thing you want to remember
when it comes to subject-verb agreement
is that a complete sentence
or an independent clause
must always have a subject and a verb
that agree, and the
subject, as a reminder,
is the person, place, or thing
that is doing or being something.
And so it is the actor.
(sound cutting out) the
act that's being executed,
and what you want to remember
in terms of agreement
is that singular subjects always go
with singular verbs, and plural subjects
go with plural verbs, and so this is
the agreement part of the
subject-verb agreement.
And this topic is one that shows up
in so many different contexts within
the SAT Writing and Language component,
and so it's worth refreshing and
making sure that you have a good
understanding of what
is a subject and verb,
what is an independent clause,
also what is a dependent clause,
and a few tips I have when it comes
to approaching subject-verb questions
are that you should find the subject
of the sentence first,
then check for agreement.
And so that's all about identifying
the actor, and so in this case the dog
is going to be your
subject, and the action
that he, that the dog is doing is barking.
And so once you know who the actor is
it makes it a lot easier to narrow down,
you know, does this agree or not?
The next tip is one
that I mentioned before,
and this is around crossing out
unnecessary words to simplify.
And so what I mean here is looking for
prepositional phrases that separate
the subject and the verb.
So the dog along with the cat was
convinced that it was nap time.
So in this case the subject is,
any thoughts on what the subject is?
If you have a guess go ahead and
type that in to the
text box, into the chat.
The subject here is the dog.
So it's just the dog, and what I can
cross out is this whole part here,
along with the cat, because that is a
prepositional phrase and
a prepositional phrase
is never the subject.
So prepositional phrase,
prepositional is such a long word
so I'm just gonna abbreviate it.
And so the dog was convinced
that it was nap time.
In this case I've identified that
and so then we have the verb here,
was convinced, and so there you have it.
So these are some quick refreshers
of what subject-verb
agreement is all about
and you might be thinking,
okay, I got it, I got it,
let's get to some practice problems.
Well I agree.
Let's do some practice problems,
apply what we've discussed about
being proactive in marking up the answers
and the questions, and keeping
all of these things in mind.
But before that I want to throw a few
questions and pronouns your way
to test what is singular
and what is plural.
So let's take a look.
So subject-verb agreement.
Are these phrases singular or plural?
And so we're gonna step
through each one of these,
and as I'm going through, if you think you
know the answer go ahead and type that in
and then I'll share the
answer and why that is.
So he or she, is it singular or plural?
So that one is singular, and that one
is more straightforward,
it's an individual.
It's referring to he or she and so
that one is more straightforward.
But what about this next
one, anyone or each one?
Anyone or each one, is
that singular or plural?
So that one is also
singular, and that's because
this is what is called
an indefinite pronoun
and it's one of those parts
of the English language
where it actually will be helpful
to memorize what pronouns
fall into this category
because indefinite pronouns
are always singular
even though they might sound like
they're referring to
multiple or many people.
So that one is also going to be singular.
What about we?
Singular or plural?
So this one is going to be plural.
And so we is referring to multiple people,
and so that one probably makes sense.
Now what about this next one of everyone
or everybody, is that gonna
be singular or plural?
And some of you all might be thinking
well is it the one?
Am I thinking about the one
and it should be singular
or am I thinking about the every,
'cause then that's talking
about lots of people.
So singular or plural?
This one is also going to be singular
and this is an indefinite pronoun, again,
and so this is another example of where
memorizing that this is
an indefinite pronoun
will help you with subject-verb
agreement questions
and making sure that you pick
the verb choice that agrees.
Now what about somebody?
Somebody, singular or plural?
That is also going to be singular.
So again, we have this indefinite pronoun
and so you're spotting the pattern here.
And so I'll move onto the next one.
The turkey as well as the chicken.
Turkey as well as the
chicken, singular or plural?
So this one is, yet again, singular.
So turkey is the subject here and
as well as the chicken is actually
a prepositional, not a
prepositional phrase,
but it does not create a compound subject
and so all of this, the only subject
in this sentence is
going to be the turkey.
Now last one, the James and I.
Singular or plural?
So this one is finally plural, and the
reason for that is and is a conjunction,
and that and creates a compound subject,
and that compound subject involves
two individuals, and that is James and I,
and so that is why that
is going to be plural.
So now we've done some of that
to kind of really give you a refresher
of some of those trickier pronouns
and now we're going to
do a practice problem.
Here is where, if you weren't
in full screen before,
it will really help so that you can
read the text and read the question.
So let's take a look.
Practice question number one.
Billy, although he had a great
sense of timing for standup comedy,
were handicapped by his poor memory.
So Billy, although he had a great sense
of timing for standup
comedy, were handicapped
by his poor memory, and so what I want
to do here is I want to find the subject.
What is the subject?
So that subject is going to be Billy.
And so this is going to be singular and
were is actually plural, and
so we have an issue here.
This should be Billy was handicapped
by his poor memory, and so we
have answer choice C there.
That does not work.
Billy have been handicapped
by his poor memory,
is incorrect, and were being handicapped,
again, does not agree given the tense
and the singular nature
of the subject there.
So that was a good warmup question.
Let's keep going to the next one.
So with the help of the Mat-Su Regional
Medical Center, middle school students
in Gateway, Alaska observe
intubation and sets bones.
So with the help of the Mat-Su Regional
Medical Center, middle school students
in Gateway, Alaska observe
intubation and sets bones.
So what do you think is the subject here?
Because that's again, the
first step that I would take,
is I would think about
what the subject is.
So subject here is going to
be middle school students.
And what is the action that they're doing?
So here is observe
intubation and sets bones,
and so this one, the question actually
helps you out here because
this observe intubation
is not underlined and so
that part has to be correct.
You can't change it and
so you have to assume
that is a given, and so this
verb, is it singular or plural?
Students observe.
Well I've got students here,
subject, this is the subject,
students there, and so this
is plural, students observe.
And what about sets bones?
So there that is actually
singular and that is not correct.
It does not agree with this subject,
which is plural over here, and so this
should be middle school
students set bones.
And so there I have it, answer choice D.
And then all of this is a
phrase that I can cross out.
So with the help of the
Mat-Su Regional Center,
that is not part of the subject and so
it's fair for me to
ignore that to simplify
the sentence and just focus
in on the plural subject
that I have here and the
verbs that I have here.
Great.
So those were two of
our three subject-verb
agreement questions,
and now we're gonna do
one final one to get some extra practice
and then we'll move onto the next concept
and do some Q and A, and then do the
writing passage with questions.
So let's keep on going.
Okay, so adventure
climbers like Alex Honnold
specializes in free solo ascents
without ropes up sheer cliff faces,
such as El Capitan in
Yosemite National Park.
So adventure climbers like Alex Honnold
specializes in free solo ascents
without ropes up sheer cliff faces.
So what do you think is the
subject in this sentence?
So we have, some of you might be thinking
it is climbers, some
of you might think it's
Alex Honnold, and so actually let me,
I'll mark those in a
different color there.
Climbers or Alex Honnold.
Now which one do you think it is?
Well it's actually gonna be climbers.
So your subject is climbers,
and the reason for that
is this phrase, like Alex Honnold,
is one of those prepositional phrases
that I had mentioned, so
prepositional phrases.
And prepositional phrases can never
be the subject of a sentence.
And so in this case it is just climbers
specializes in free solo ascents,
and so specializes is
going to be your verb here,
and so we've got subject there and
that's gonna be plural subject.
So plural, and then specializes,
is that singular or plural?
Climbers specializes.
So specializes is incorrect.
It should be specialize,
so we gotta take that off.
And so there is going to be
our answer, answer choice C.
The rest of this sentence is great.
So free solo ascents in
El Capitan in Yosemite,
great places.
It's a great national park.
You should go if you haven't been,
but it doesn't really
matter for the grammar
and accuracy of the
sentence, and so if you
just focus in on the subject and the verb
and just cross out prepositional phrases
and focus in on climbers here and
specializes it really helps to simplify
the sentence and focus
in on what the error is.
And what you'll notice is
I've been doing something
interesting here in
these practice problems
in that I have dissected the sentence
by looking at the subject,
and then I figured out,
you know, is this right or not?
Right or not.
And then if it's been wrong
I've asked how would I fix,
how to fix, and with that it makes it
a lot easier to figure out, you know,
is it no change, is it
B, is it C, is it D?
And so knowing if it's grammatically
correct or not, predicting how to fix it,
and then matching to the
answer can really help.
So those are the subject-verb agreement
questions that we have for today
and now I'm going to move
onto sentence punctuation,
and in particular within
sentence punctuation,
and this really builds off of the
subject-verb agreement
that we've started out with
because subject and verbs, so a complete
independent clause will
have a subject and a verb
and what we're about to get into,
how you connect independent
and dependent clauses
depends all on your ability to figure out
is this a complete
sentence by itself or not?
So hopefully you're (sound
cutting out) joining us midway.
Feel free to back up and watch and
you'll catch up eventually.
So let's look at sentence
punctuation next,
which is another really common topic
that you'll see on the SAT writing.
So sentence punctuation,
and so let's take a look.
The first two pieces of punctuation
I'm gonna look at are the
semicolon and the period,
and these, as a refresher, are used
to separate two independent clauses
that each have a subject and a verb.
That's the definition of an independent
clause or a complete sentence.
You want to have a subject and a verb.
An example here is Yoda
can read minds, semicolon,
I hate playing card games against him!
And so I'll just make this very clear
and so this is an independent clause here
and this is another
independent clause here.
Now the next piece of
punctuation is the comma
and the conjunction, and so these are used
to join clauses by converting one clause
into a dependent clause.
An example sentence here is George Lucas
is a creative genius,
comma, but Episode III
was not his best work.
And so that's a comma and a conjunction,
and so this is going to
be your independent clause
and then this is going to be
your dependent clause there.
Finally I have the dash and the semicolon,
and these are used to
introduce a list, quote,
or explanation, and what
you want to remember
is that the part of the sentence
that comes before the dash or the colon
must be an independent clause.
An example here is Star Wars movies always
start with the same phrase, colon,
a long time ago in a galaxy far, far away.
And so this first part
is an independent clause
and so that's what makes
this semicolon correct,
and in case you can't tell already,
I'm a big Star Wars
fan, so hopefully these
sentences weren't too agonizing for you.
So that's a quick refresher on a few
of the most important types of punctuation
that you want to know how to work with and
interact with on the SAT
Writing and Language test.
Now we're gonna do some practice problems
to apply what you've learned and
see what it's like in context.
Okay, so again, if you're just joining us
you'll want a full screen just so you can
read the question and the
sentences more easily.
So President Thomas Jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream, he hoped to find
a living woolly mammoth in
the western United States.
So President Thomas Jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream, he hoped to find
a living woolly mammoth in
the western United States.
Okay, so what I want to
do here, so I'll just
emphasize that, that that's a comma,
is figure out what kind of
clauses I am connecting.
So this is clause number one
and this is clause number two.
So clause number one, is that an
independent or a dependent clause?
So does it have a, if it's independent
it's gonna have a subject and verb
by itself and be able to stand alone.
So hopefully you said that
that was an independent clause.
And then what about the second one?
He hoped to find a living woolly mammoth
in the western United States.
So that one's also an independent clause
and in this case, which
type of punctuation
do you think works here?
Is it going to be no change,
a colon, semicolon, or a dash?
So in this case it's going
to be answer choice B
because the second part of this sentence
connects directly to the first
and explains what Jefferson's
unusual dream was,
and so you can, it logically follows
and it is the first part of the sentence,
introduces the second part, which explains
the dream that he had.
And so that is going to be
your answer choice there,
and you'll notice that I'm
writing B in big block letters,
and the reason for that
is that writing this out
makes it faster to transfer answers
to the bubble sheet, so faster bubbling,
and it reduces the chance
of a careless mistake,
reduces the chance of a careless mistake,
that is, bubbling in the wrong answer
and carrying the wrong one over.
Chance of careless mistakes.
Great.
So that was one example.
Let's keep on going to the next one.
So this year's Shark Week
on the Discovery Channel
features the rarely-seen sharks
of the Cuban coral reefs; footage includes
in-water and on-water
activities with sharks.
And in case it's hard to
see, that is a semicolon.
So this year's Shark
Week, and so here again
this first clause, is it
independent or dependent?
It's gonna be an independent clause.
And then footage includes in-water
and on-water activities with sharks.
What about clause number two?
Does it have a subject and
verb and can it stand alone?
Yes it can, so that
one is also going to be
an independent clause, and so you have
two independent clauses that are related
and what are the ways to
connect two independent clauses?
Well we've got the period
or we've got the semicolon,
or we could do a comma and conjunction.
And so let's see which
one would work best here.
Well semicolon, that checks out.
Reefs, colon, umm,
footage includes in-water
and on-water activities.
I'll keep that one.
That's a possibility.
Semicolon and, nope.
So if I have a semicolon that connects
two independent clauses enough.
And then reefs, comma.
Well a comma by itself does not work
because it needs a conjunction to be able
to connect two independent
clauses like that.
So that is out, and so you're down to two.
In this case I'm gonna go
with the answer choice A,
and the reason A is correct is that
this footage actually does...
So one is that these are
two independent clauses
and the second reason is that this footage
doesn't tie directly
back to the rarely seen
sharks directly, and so this no change
and semicolon does the best job
of connecting the two
clauses, but in this case
I would have had to ponder a little bit
about this, but in this case the semicolon
does the cleanest, easiest, clearest job
of separating these two
independent clauses,
and so it's gonna be
answer choice A there.
This is the last question, but before
we get to the last question,
I want to emphasize
a few things about the
approach I've been taking.
As you'll see with these
sentence punctuation
practice questions I've
been really focusing
on figuring out what kinds
of clauses am I connecting.
Am I looking at an
independent and dependent,
independent and independent clause,
and as you practice more you'll get
better and faster at identifying
what kinds of clauses you're dealing with,
and therefore what kind of punctuation
would make the sentence
grammatically correct.
Then similarly to before, once I know
what I'm working with, I ask myself
is this correct or not, and
if not, how would I fix it?
And with that in mind I can then
get to the final answer much more quickly.
So this last one is a bit longer
and so get ready, but don't worry.
You follow all the exact same processes
and like I mentioned before,
if you have questions,
feel free to add them into the
YouTube chat and I'll answer them shortly.
So last one.
Contrary to the popular perception
that DNA was Watson and
Crick's discovery, colon,
its helical structure
and phosphate backbone
were first recognized by a woman,
and that one is a semicolon,
the English chemist Rosalind Franklin.
So I've got three clauses here.
Contrary to the popular
perception that DNA
was Watson and Crick's discovery.
This is clause number two, and I've got
clause number three here.
What am I working with
with clause number one?
So that's gonna be a dependent clause.
So I don't have a, the reason I know
that is one, the clause
starts out with contrary,
and I don't have a subject there.
So then what about number two?
Its helical structure
and phosphate backbone
were first recognized by a woman.
Is that an independent
or dependent clause?
Does it have a complete subject and
verb and can it stand on its own?
So that one is a perfectly
fine complete sentence,
and so that's gonna be
an independent clause.
And what about number three?
The English chemist Rosalind Franklin.
So I definitely have a subject there
but I don't have a verb, and so
that's gonna be a dependent clause.
And so now in terms of connecting
this dependent and independent clause,
what about this first,
clauses one and two?
Well I've got a dependent and independent,
and so, and I have a conjunction here,
and so I think a comma will
serve me quite well there.
So contrary to the popular perception
that DNA was Watson and
Crick's discovery, comma,
its helical structure
and phosphate backbone
were first recognized by a woman.
And so that's an independent
and a dependent clause.
Can I connect these two, can I connect
an independent and dependent
clause with a semicolon?
You cannot, but I could use a colon here
since the English
chemist Rosalind Franklin
is explaining who this woman is,
and this, we mentioned,
was an independent clause,
and so I want to look for an answer
that has a comma and a semicolon.
And so discovery, comma,
its helical structure
and phosphate backbone
were first recognized
by a woman, semicolon, so that's out.
We said that that was wrong.
So comma and semicolon, boom.
There is my final answer.
So as you saw, I kinda broke down
all of the clauses here and then
figured out what I needed to
correctly connect all of them.
And so that question had a little more
text involved, it was a little trickier,
but if you kind of break down the sentence
piece by piece, be really
active as you go through it,
you can really simplify
and, even if it looks
complicated at first, you can
get to the right final answer.
So now I'm gonna do a few questions,
and before I jump into
the writing passage.
So if you have questions
feel free to throw them
in there, into the chat, and
I'll get to as many as I can.
Let's see.
Is it necessary to read and annotate
parts of the passage that have
no questions directed to them?
Great question and, you know,
you're probably thinking,
well if there are no
questions underlined in the,
if there are no questions in that part
of the passage do I need
to pay as much attention?
And I would actually
say the answer is yes,
and the reason for that is that there are
questions in the SAT
Writing and Language test
that depend on the context,
and almost all of them
actually depend on the context,
and in particular, questions like
should you add or delete this sentence,
or sentence seven should
best be placed where?
All of those questions rely on the context
of the paragraph and of the passage,
and so if you've skipped over or
kind of glossed over those parts
you won't have that critical piece
of information that will actually
help you answer the question about
adding or deleting a sentence,
moving a sentence, so on and so forth.
So absolutely.
You should definitely be paying attention
even if the part of the passage
isn't underlined as having
a question about it.
Okay, how do you suggest we practice
how to speed our test taking pace?
So there are a few things
I would suggest there.
The first would be to go on Khan Academy
Official SAT Practice and after you finish
three writing, evidence-based
reading and writing
practice sessions you'll be able to unlock
a timed mini section, and so these are
timed 11-question writing
or reading passages
where on Khan Academy the timer
will tick down, and so that's a great way
to pace yourself through one passage.
The second way I would
suggest you practice
your timing and pacing is by doing a
full length practice test, and if you find
that you mainly have problems
in the writing section,
practice those full writing sections,
have a timer, you know, kind of calculate
if you have 35 questions
and four passages,
35 divided by four is gonna be roughly
nine minutes per passage and so that
can be a good mental
model, and so practicing
that pacing from start to finish
would be the second
way that I would do it,
and so the more practice you have
with the real timer, the better
and faster you're going to be.
Let's see.
How should we write our essay?
Like what format would be best?
Maybe a five paragraph essay.
So great question, and
so when it comes to the
essay I wouldn't focus
purely on the structure.
I think if you are comfortable with
a five paragraph essay and you've gotten
used to that in class, that is completely
okay to use, but what you want to focus on
with the SAT Writing and Language Essay
is to really, to not restate
what the author is saying,
because every SAT write essay prompt
will focus on, will ask you to dissect
how the author makes his or her argument
using evidence, using persuasive elements
and stylistic elements, and so you really
want to focus more on
answering that prompt
and saying, and articulating what pieces
in the author's writing
reinforces his or her point
and how that is done in the essay.
And you can actually go and practice
writing an essay on Official SAT Practice,
and we have an essay practice where
you can do some pre-writing,
do some writing,
and then we'll actually generate a score
for your essay to tell you where
your strengths and weaknesses are.
So that's all the time we
have for questions now,
so I'm gonna jump over to
doing the practice passage.
We're going to go through as many
questions as we can before we wrap up.
Let's take a look now at the context
of a real SAT writing passage.
Okay, so again here it
will be really important
to zoom in as I'm reading the passage.
So the Political Power of First Ladies.
A high-profile, unelected
official with the
political resources to
influence domestic policy,
the President of the
United States has a wife,
known as the First Lady,
occupies a unique position.
Many First Ladies, not content with simply
playing the role of demure wife
and social hostess, have
taken an active role
in the political sphere.
And I'm gonna go back to there.
Even though her power
comes by way of marriage
rather than from the
electorate or Constitution,
the First Lady or First Gentleman
has a responsibility to capitalize
on her situation and attempt to
create significant, lasting change.
If the President of the
United States is female,
her husband's title
would be First Gentleman.
Throughout US history, there have been
a number of influential,
politically engaged
First Ladies from whom future First Ladies
or Gentlemen can take inspiration.
Great, so we're talking about First Ladies
and First Gentlemen and their obligation
to be politically engaged and create
positive change, and
I've started the first
and last sentence 'cause those tend
to be really important to helping
me understand the passage.
So Abigail Adams, the second First Lady
in American history, was first to assume
a protruding role in the political sphere.
Unlike her predecessor, Martha Washington,
Adams was outspoken, well-educated,
and quickly developed the reputation
of a staunch partisan defender
after openly criticizing Congress
for not declaring war on France in 1798.
Her influence is so well known
that opponents claimed the President
refused to make any appointments
without her approbation,
and aspiring politicians
sought her endorsement.
In recent years, Adams has become
a popular topic for
biographers because of her
thoughts on gender, slavery, and politics.
Okay, so we're talking
about Abigail Adams here
in the second part and her achievements.
And so we'll just read
to that point for now
because of time and we'll
tackle the first question here.
I'll zoom in a little bit
more so that you can see it.
So question one of 11.
And so you might be wondering,
well what is the question?
Well this is what's called
a stemless question,
and what you want to do here is go back
and find the number one in the passage,
which is right here, and with that
determine whether you would make
no change or if there is a change
that would need to be made to either
strengthen the
communication in the passage
or fix a grammatical error.
So if you recall, we started this session
by saying those were the two main
types of questions you can get,
and so let's look at question number one
and then we'll read some
of the context and see.
So high profile elected official
with the political resources
to influence domestic policy,
the President of the United States
has a wife, known as the First Lady,
occupies a unique position.
So can any of you, so first question.
Is there an error or not?
So hint, there is an error.
So it is not no change, but can any of you
spot what the error is in number one?
It is what's called a modifier error,
and what that means is
that we're talking about
the First Lady here, so a high-profile
unelected official, that's the First Lady,
and then we also followed up with,
known as the First Lady,
and so what's odd here
is that we have all of these phrases
about the First Lady and then phrase one
says the President of the
United States has a wife.
Well all modifiers should be placed
very close to, as close as possible to
the object they're describing for clarity,
because in this case we're talking about
the First Lady but then we have
the President right here,
and so it makes it confusing.
Are we talking about the First Lady
or are we talking about the President?
And so in this case, the way you would
correct this is with answer choice D,
because it focuses on the wife
of the President of the United States,
whereas in answer choice
C, the United States'
President has a wife, we're
again focusing on the President.
And then in answer choice
B we're talking about
the United States, which
is not even a person.
And so this is, the error here is a
modifier placement error,
and so answer choice D
clarifies that by--
(sound cutting out)
Let's take a--
The First Lady has a
responsibility to capitalize
and create significant, lasting change.
And then if the President
of the United States
is female, here husband's
title would be First Gentleman.
Throughout history there have been
a number of influential
and politically engaged
First Ladies from whom future First Ladies
or Gentlemen can take inspiration.
So the first question you want to answer
is should this be kept or deleted,
because if you look at
the answer choices here
we've got two keeps and two deletes.
And so if you can make that decision,
it cuts out half of the options,
and what I like to ask myself here
is does sentence number two, does it add
something meaningful or
not, is it repetitive?
And does it add relevant information?
And so those are some of the questions
that I like to ask myself
when I make this decision,
and so we have, if the
President of the United States
is female her title
will be First Gentleman,
and so to me that is an interesting point,
but it's also something that we have here,
First Lady or First Gentleman.
So we mention it, so it is repetitive.
That's one strike for deleting it.
And then the next thing I want to ask is
is it relevant?
It does relate to the passage,
but here we talk about
creating significant
lasting change, and then
in the last sentence
we talk about influential and politically
engaged First Ladies,
and making an impact.
And so it's not super relevant to making
that point of lasting
change and political impact.
And so that gives me
confidence that we should
not keep it, and so here we have deleted,
because it it interrupts the introduction
of the passage's main argument
with a loosely related detail.
Delete it because it weakens the passage's
influence on the importance of work
done by several influential First Ladies.
Well C is the closest
to what I was discussing
because it does interrupt the main point,
and it is a loosely related
detail but not significant.
Great.
So now let's look at number three.
Which choice is most consistent with the
writer's position as
established in the passage?
Most consistent, so this, if we look back
at number three, Abigail Adams,
the second First Lady in America,
was the first to assume a protruding role,
so we're looking here.
Unlike her predecessor,
Adams was outspoken,
well-educated, and quickly developed
a reputation of a staunch
partisan defender,
and so this is all pretty positive.
A protruding role, and
so this is essentially
a way of asking, what does
protruding mean in context
or what might substitute
within for protruding?
So I'm gonna say a influential role
would be my guess, influential.
And so let's see which one matches that.
Most consistent with
the writer's position,
and so the writer's position actually,
this question is actually not asking
what could go in place of number three,
but what most fits within
the author's meaning
and intent within the
rest of the paragraph?
And it's pretty positive, influential,
and it's a pretty positive regard.
So protruding, does that mean
influential and positive?
Well sort of.
Protruding means kind of standing out,
but it has a bit of a
negative connotation,
so a bit negative, and so
I don't think it's that
but I won't cross it off yet.
And then what about
obstrusive, an obstrusive one?
So again, let's say maybe you didn't know
what that meant, and so
I'll skip that for now.
What about a prominent one?
Prominent does mean influential
and it is pretty positive, so that one
has two checks in its favor.
An ostentatious one.
Ostentatious.
So this one also does not fit, but say
you didn't know what that meant and
you only had this to go off of.
Well in this case you should always guess
because there is no guessing penalty,
and so even if you have it down to this
and you're thinking, well
maybe this one isn't it
so go ahead and cross that one out,
and then you're left with these three.
If you're getting a
pretty strong signal from
the smiley face and two checks
that this does fit with
the writer's position
with regard to Abigail
Adams, then go ahead
and select C and in that case
you would have been right,
because an obstrusive,
obstrusive actually means
something very similar to protruding,
so it kind of sticks out, but
kind of in a negative way.
And then ostentatious is another word
that kinda means braggy,
or showy, and so it has
some negative connotations, and so
that would have been out as well.
So I'll do one more question and
then we'll wrap it up because of time.
But let's take a look.
So number four.
So this is a stemless question again,
so I want to look at question number four.
Should it be changed or not?
And so let's see.
So you had a protruding
role and her influence
is so well known that opponents claim
the President refused
to make any appointments
without her approbation, and aspiring
politicians sought her endorsement.
And so this is a verb,
and so her influence
is so well known is this,
is any change needed?
Is there any kind of
grammatical error at all?
Well I think there is,
because if you notice
the tenses of the rest of the sentence
are claimed, in the past tense, refused,
in the past tense,
sought, in the past tense,
yet is is in the present tense.
So I think what would fix this is
was, and so her influence
was so well known
that all of these politicians
helped her and admired her.
Great, so that is a glimpse at what
the SAT Writing and Language section
looks like within the
context of a real passage,
and what I want to emphasize there is that
the context of the passage,
so all of the parts
before and after the underlined portions,
are very important for
you to pay attention to
because they inform the
answer of all of the
questions that you're prompted and what
you need to look into in
the underlined portion,
and so I know we didn't
get through all of it,
but if you want more
practice with this passage
and those like it go to
Official SAT Practice
and do those practice sessions either
untimed if you're just
starting out, or do them timed
so that you can simulate
the real situation.
Now the last thing I'll share with you
is an SAT badge, a Khan Academy badge
for attending this class, and so go ahead
and look in the chat room and we'll be
sharing a link to a badge that you can get
for attending this
class, and what you'll do
is click on the link, head to Khan Academy
and then log in, and once
you log in you'll see
in the top right hand
corner of your screen
a notification pop-up that says,
hey you've got the Khan
Academy SAT Writing badge.
And so I'll leave you with that,
and for those of you who are taking
the SAT this Saturday,
a few tips I would share
is just to relax ahead of the test.
Don't stress out, don't try and cram
10 practice tests before then.
What's most important right now is
really getting enough rest, eating well,
and preparing all the
materials. and admission ticket,
and pencils that you need for test day.
Don't try and do any crazy cramming
before Saturday because you've just got
a few days left and it can often be
counterproductive to stress yourself out.
On Khan Academy in our
Tips and Strategies section
we also have a number of articles
for what you should be
doing the week before,
and the day before, and how you can
get ready in those last 24 hours.
If you're taking the test this Saturday,
best of luck to you, and for those who
have been with us over the course of these
three classes, I hope this has been
helpful for you, and I know it's been fun
for me and all of us at Khan Academy,
so thanks so much for joining us
and we might see you again in the future.
Take care.